[Music]
how you notice with salon de The Girl
with the Dragon Tattoo the girl who
hurts men I'm transferring all of your
cash to your wife
he want you again why did you help
everyone but me I've been told you're
the only person who can pull this off
that depends what am I looking for
I realized too late that I created an
abomination you want me to steal it for
you please help me I need your help
who's that
that's what I want to know
attract all of his ex associates every
single one leads back to one place
home for 16 years
Bethan letant this moment this Basilica
[Applause]
someone always has to carry the pain now
it's your turn
sister itself
she's been behind all of this
whatever she's planning it's bigger than
just you I know what just take apart
we're running out of time
now the world will burn
thank everyone window
it was you who lit the match what you
thought she didn't have a plan
[Music]
follow me
[Music]
Salander personnel only don't understand
what this is doing
America country something somebody like
you wouldn't understand I understand how
to open that door
oh you're just jumping up to you
you stop
on the floor now
get in the van
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I've imagined this moment for so long I
had to go to speech prepared I don't
care just shoot me shoot you you're my
sister
someone always has to carry the pain
that's about it
[Music]
why you not Lisbeth Salander the girl
who hurts men who hurt women
Elizabeth is a bit of a vigilante and
justice is not something that she thinks
is ever served she for a long time had
something to fight against we sought to
find her in this film pretty lost
[Music]
she knows that she's was accepted by
society and she doesn't care
this but they're hunting me were they
that's what I want to know she's
stronger than she looks and he doesn't
play by the rules
who are you you should ask yourself that
question
sorry I said it's the best thing you
know what you love you don't you
[Music]
the hell are you
[Applause]
I'm a fan of yours the CEO will beat up
two prostitutes but then got acquitted
in court yesterday I'm transferring 20%
of your cash for these two girls I'm
Khaleel all to security the rest I'm
transferring to your wife account number
don't what take your charger nice he
won't hurt you again mr. Chan has bank
called your company for years isn't this
his wife Ritz we try to contact your
wife again
what if anything unexpected should
happen to her this video will be sent to
me
[Music]
are you not visible select the writer of
wrongs
the girl who hurts men who had me
I could never figure it out
why did you have everyone but me
Conte our time heroes
why is it this but why is it artists who
get stuck in their own webs
I do not least with salamba The Girl
with the Dragon Tattoo
[Music]
hello everybody I hope you really enjoy
gun and a spider's web I'm really
excited if you to watch it
[Music]
we're at the room Film Festival where
I'm showing a spider's web tonight just
really excited to premiere the movie in
Rome and Europe with a movie like this
one is kinda perfect place I'm so
excited to be a part of making the
Swedish story international for me it's
a lot of memories wonderful memories of
making a movie with Betty and Claire and
I just had so much fun and I'm just I
can't wait to see the result I know what
she's capable off by running out of time
when I watched it the first time that I
was taken away with the pace like and I
was breathless by the end of it it was
quite overwhelmed so I'm quite
interested to look around at some points
ago how they run to it as a wrong
feeling has anyone taken a breath yet
now the work will burn thank to everyone
one dollar
it was you who lit the match
[Music]
you